my grandmother survived the holocaust in
the most badass way
and this is that story
she was a teenager when the nazis
started to invade poland
this one older guy had the hots for my
grandmother and he wanted this special
suit to be made
this guy who needed a suit was well off
his name was leon
so she suggested that he go to her
father
who was a tailor he asked my great
grandfather
the tailor to make him a suit with
special pockets so he could hide jewelry
and money
my grandmother was pretty popular at the
time so she
kind of strung him along a bit she
always said that she had noticed that he
had really
big hands and really nice teeth
apparently
this guy was kind of a ladies man we're
not really sure who pursued her
sometime after september 1939
her family and friends were forced into
a work camp in poland
despite the harsh conditions her
relationship with leon
continued to grow in late 1943
everyone was moved to a different camp
specifically majalka
one day the german officers gave shovels
to my grandmother
her friends family and 300 other people
so they could start digging their graves
the plan was to shoot them all so they
would fall into the graves that they dug
my grandmother was not having it she
jumped on the officer's back his name
was shroff and started choking him
keep in mind she was 19 or 20 at this
time
like i said badass she always made a
point
to say that she dug her fingernails into
his neck
in the midst of the fight he wrestled
her to the ground
and shot her in the head
but what shroth didn't know was that the
bullet
just grazed her forehead there was lots
of blood
but she played dead suddenly
there was an air raid or something and
the officers got distracted
everyone prisoners and officers alike
ended up going back to the barracks so
no one ended up getting killed that day
my grandmother stayed there bleeding for
a long time
she claims it was all night
then she went back to the barracks and
was like
surprise i'm alive everyone she was with
ended up hiding her under the barracks
the next day
while on patrol the guards noticed my
grandmother's body
wasn't where they had left her they knew
she was hiding
give her to us or else will kill all of
you so of course
they give her up and the guards beat her
up some more from there
she was put in a jail and a high-ranking
officer
was threatening to kill her as all hopes
seem lost
in comes leon he bribes the commander
with jewelry specifically a diamond he
had hidden
in his secret pockets that was sewn in
by her father
this bribe saved her life
on a different night shroth the man who
attempted to kill my grandmother
was drunk at the barracks he was waving
his gun
saying he was going to shoot everyone
now my grandmother was really sharp
she knew high german so she was always
able to communicate with the nazis
even though she didn't go through all
her schooling she was
pretty much fluent in five languages
german
polish english yiddish and hebrew
she was able to use this to her
advantage because she was able to calm
shroff down
he ended up leaving the barracks without
killing anyone that night
some time passes and everyone in the
barracks
including leon is sent off to various
camps
my grandmother and her family were
deported to auschwitz
once there her brother and father get
sent to buna work camp
in january 1945 her and her mother
marched to ravensbruck her mother
gets ill after the march and ends up in
the infirmary
my grandmother visits her every day she
knew her mother
was close to death so she cut off a lock
of her hair
the next day when she went back to the
infirmary her mother was gone
my grandmother kept that lock of hair in
a locket
she always wore around her neck
[Music]
fast forward to the end of the war and
the camps get liberated
my grandmother ends up in sweden with
the red cross
she learns that leon had survived and
was in a hospital in germany
she finds out that her brother and
father had died
so she tracks down leon she finds him
and meets his remaining family in berlin
and they get married shortly after
in 1947 they moved to charleston south
carolina
they had six kids one of which is my
father
my grandfather owned a bunch of
businesses and my grandmother
owned a dressmaking shop they were
together until my grandfather died in
1973.
my grandmother actually went to court to
testify
against shroth and help put him away
[Music]
would you tell me your name please you
are starting
okay my name is
guta blas weintraub
my maid name is blas and my married name
is wine crowd
[Music]
you